two uninhabited Pacific Islands more than 5,000 miles from the UK one will be inhabited by 14
British men while a separate island will be home to 14 British women for six weeks they'll
be utterly alone with only the clothes they stand up in and a handful of basic tools filming
everything themselves when pushed to the limits of human endurance so thin now will it be brute
power or mental strength the winds a day watch him watch him go now go now who will have what
it takes to stay alive tonight we follow the women's island survival will be harder than
ever they'll have to make fire
hunt for food and find water oh living on the island in the middle of Tropical storm season
I'm still wet worse night's sleep like surely I'm gonna die soon hang on
when pitted against the extremes of nature
have these Monday women got what it takes to survive
just remember to how you felt when you felt and leave it there
it's been seven days since 14 British women were marooned on a remote Pacific Island
brutal conditions have already claimed two victims
I need to go it's been with my family and the group paid the price when they split to
find a sustainable water source we cannot walk anywhere on this island without getting lost
finally reunited after three days apart the women find themselves on the northern tip of the island
they have no water source and many haven't had a drop to drink for two days
it's sunny
so it is blaring so hot there is no outside input and it is up to us to survive and thrive
that is a heck of a challenge
oh my gosh
despite the oppressive
30 degree heat there's something to celebrate for one of the party if you'd
have asked me a year ago where I'll be spending my 25th birthday I definitely
would not have been saying oh my 25th birthday will be spent abandoned on an
island dehydrated and starving for the last five days the women have barely
eaten and had hardly anything to drink finding water it's a priority the only
reason we're not thinking about food is because we're so thirsty our body
basically tries and like compensates for everything that we're lacking when it
comes to survival I often talk about the rule of three which means you can survive
three minutes without air three days without water three weeks without food
and in temperatures like this the water is not enough for you to survive you
women have got to drink a lot between two or four liters of water a day if
they don't they're finished the Sun obviously makes you feel more dehydrated
and more weak without a sustainable water source they're surviving on rain
water but there hasn't been a drop for 48 hours looking at the sea you just
want to drink the sea water keep dreaming about the sea you just want to drink the sea water keep dreaming about the sea
it's really about diet iron brew cold freezing cold diet iron brew with ice
oh my god my other birthday's and I'm stressing out because no one's got me a
card or no one's come out for a meal and I'm just gonna be happy with some a
piece of fruit and some water
I think a bogey just came out my nose
eat it! eat it! eat it!
Waste! Waste nothing!
I've always loved adventure.
In December 2013, I set off on transatlantic rowing race,
3,000 miles across to Antigua.
It's the 30th of January and we have just had a capsize.
I have split my head open.
I didn't want to give up.
It had been 96 days of pushing my body and pushing my mind
further than I ever had before,
but we still had to give up.
So that's hard to come to terms with.
I will not get off the island.
I have to prove to myself that I can do it.
Happy birthday, Lauren.
Superwoman.
She's keeping us all sane.
Celebrations are short-lived.
The women have a life-or-death priority.
Seeing the effect that dehydration has,
I couldn't really have predicted that it could be so disabling.
They were going to be a little bit more than that.
We ain't coming back until we've found water.
Georgie leads a group on a scouting mission
into the thick jungle.
There are no pools, which is what we're after.
I've made sure that the island has got enough water,
indigenous animals, and vegetation on it to keep them alive,
but only if they've got the ingenuity to find it,
That's quite a deep pool. It's empty.
It's just the same shit.
If we don't find water, we're screwed.
What is that?
Oh, my God, there's two piglets!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
Be careful cos if Mum's there...
I can actually see Mum over here.
Oh, oh, careful. Come away.
If Mum thinks the kids are threatened,
that's when they get really aggressive.
She's lying down. Come away, sweetheart.
She's massive. She's enormous.
She's, like, really near.
The piglets, the first thing I thought of was crackling,
to be honest.
I am hungry.
I don't think I could look into his little piggy eyes
and then kill him. I'm not ready for that yet.
But then again,
by the time I come home,
I'll probably be a full-blown fucking, I don't know, cannibal.
The pigs are given a reprieve.
Right now, everyone's lives depend on finding water.
What are we going to do?
You can sit down.
Oh!
Ah!
We're all buggered.
No energy to move.
Brian? You all right?
Are you OK? What's wrong?
Whenever I stand up, I just see all black.
That's dehydration, babe.
The situation is now critical.
We're going foraging. Water.
In a do-or-die attempt to find water...
Please be careful.
..Georgie and Fi strike out in the midday sun.
I just think...
I just couldn't sit and wilt in that sun down there.
The weather here is brutal.
You know, you've got 90%-plus humidity.
The heat here is oppressive.
So finding that fresh water source is vital.
The bottom line is, you go three days without it, you're dead.
It's so hot today. So, so hot.
I think we should look on here and then go back.
I think I'm being in a much better way.
I'm not eating.
Really fast.
Ooh!
Hard work.
It's water. Ah! This looks good.
Jesus Christ!
We did it!
Oh, yeah, baby.
I don't give a fuck where that came from.
We're drinking it.
Oh!
Amazing.
So, we hit the jackpot.
Picked this out.
OK, it's not over yet.
But you know what?
If I die, I don't care.
At least I don't die thirsty.
Hmm.
Obviously, rain itself is drinkable without purification.
But once it hits the ground, it becomes contaminated.
All sorts of bacterias and nasties there.
And no matter how clean the water looks, you've got to boil it.
Guess what I've got?
Water!
Oh, yeah!
Oh, my God!
I'm not going to lie to you.
You drink it at your own risk.
It came from a waterfall, and it tastes fine.
Don't drink it.
Every water from waterfall, river, whatever,
has to be filtered and boiled.
Because of the parasites, it's just...
It's a death trap.
Complete.
The whole island is a death trap.
The thing is, though, we need to get this fire started,
because if we don't get this fire started, we're back to zero again.
We're back to no fucking water.
They haven't been able to start a fire for three days.
If they're to survive, this is their last chance.
Oh, my God.
I won't stop until the fire is ready.
Because then I know that we can drink.
Yeah.
Just go through that smoke.
Pretend it's not even smoking.
I think we've got it, I think we've got it.
Go, stop, stop.
It's really hard.
And again, and again.
It's got enough...
It's there, it's there, it's there.
Well done!
Guys, we've got fire!
Well done, girls!
Woo!
Can we just taste the water?
Ah, look, look, look, look, look, look.
Look at that fire.
The water won't be safe to drink
until it has boiled some three hours later.
Meanwhile, Lauren's keeping the fire going.
The fire is so hot, it's burning through everything.
The busty girl...
Yeah.
..is doing all the hard work, and she's exhausted.
I'd say that Lauren and Beth...
Lauren and Beth...
..are always the first in there to help.
Rosé, they think of things.
Oh, shit!
Lauren, Lauren, come this way, this way, this way!
Go to the sea now!
Fucking hell!
Shit!
She opened the lid and it just exploded in our face.
Oh, fuck!
Right in there, babe!
Get her right immersed in the sea.
Jesus!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, shit!
Lauren, come this way, this way, this way!
Go to the sea!
Go into the sea now!
Go right into the sea, cos it's cold.
Day seven on the island,
and Lauren's been tending a jerrycan of boiling water on the fire.
She opened the lid and it just exploded in our face.
Jesus! What's happened? What's happened?
The pressure of the jerrycan has exploded.
How are you feeling?
Fine. OK.
Stay there for now. Keep in the water.
For the moment, Dr Belinda can't tell how badly scolded Lauren is.
What you say is to run whatever it is under cold water for exactly...
We'll see the extent of it in a minute.
Just everything seems to be going a bit...
It's just her 15 years old,
so she thinks Lauren's, like, one of our strongest people.
So if she goes down, I think it would be a big detriment to us.
It's like doing your water on your engine.
You've got to let it cool down before you open the top screw top.
If her burns prove to be severe,
Lauren will be in trouble.
Lauren may have to be evacuated.
Poor Lauren. She's not having the best birthday ever.
She's dehydrated and now scolded by boiling water.
I'm just going to keep dampening you and letting it cool.
Hopefully she will be back to full strength soon.
Lauren's face isn't scolded,
and Dr Belinda believes she can treat the burns on her arm.
Especially in the blistered area. That's the worst bit.
It feels like someone is singeing my arm with a hot poker.
I feel like people see that I'm feeling just as weak as them
because I actually feel like some people need strength
and other people to keep them going,
and I'm determined to be that person.
It's alive!
I'm still standing.
It won't get boring, it won't get boring.
Despite the jerrycan exploding,
just enough water remains for everyone to have a life-saving drink.
Pick your own bottle.
Is it all the same?
You just used it once.
No, I asked for whisky and coke.
Oh, I've went for some aloe vera.
Original drink.
And aloe vera is disgusting.
I tried it with a detox and it tastes like sperm.
There's a pig! Pig! There!
Oh, yeah!
Now they have a water source, food.
Food should be the women's big priority.
Biggie, biggie, biggies!
Hello!
All they've eaten in a week
are a few handfuls of yucca and coconut.
We've got two of the cutest little piglets here.
Their little tails wag like dogs. They're so cute.
Everything that moves on that island
really should be seen as a potential source of food,
and that includes the pigs.
Oh, you're so cute! Come here, Sage!
Onion!
Ooh!
To befriend them is just going to make the decision
to kill them a thousand times more difficult.
And really, in survival, there's no room for sentiment.
Sorry, I'm just being joined here.
I can hear you squeaking. What are you squeaking about?
And everyone's like, oh, they're so cute, they're so cute.
Like, we're going to eat them as pets.
And I'm like, I'm just thinking, you know,
put that girl's, like...
We're literally going to slice and dice those piggies.
Definitely, we're eating them.
Suckling pig.
Nah.
Would you not eat them?
No, they're so cute.
I don't care that they're cute.
As the time goes on, we'll be hungrier and hungrier,
but I am not killing the little piglets and eating them.
No way.
They're so funny.
Argh!
I've been a vegetarian basically since I was born.
I think it's going to be a massive challenge,
if I have to, by choice, eat meat.
But then again, maybe it's not going to be a choice,
because I'll be so starving and I'll just have to eat it.
I would definitely say I'm an animal person
rather than a people's person.
You know, animals are less stressful sometimes.
I will train them pigs.
I'll kick them up the arse.
The moral argument is,
is do we now eat the pigs,
but then do you kill, essentially, your pet?
Piggy, piggy, piggies.
Sagey, onion.
With water running low...
Careful, these rocks are uber fucking slippy.
..an expedition party makes the hazardous journey
back to the waterfall.
That's it, guys, we're nearly there.
Jamie, hang on.
Oh!
Shit.
I saved the camera!
Good job.
That's it there.
Shit doesn't look like it's running, for fuck's sake.
No!
I don't understand.
This was pouring with water the other day.
And it's dry.
It's like...
Toll-oo.
Every day, it's gone.
The water source may be dry,
but fortunately in the tropics,
the weather can change in an instant.
Look at that.
I've never seen such a dirty grey cloud as that.
Oh, here it comes!
Let's get water quick before this happens.
Can you pass me the bottle one by one and pass them over to me?
Violent Pacific storms can dump an inch of water in an hour.
The women need to take their chances when they can.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
We need to try and protect the fire!
The wood's getting saturated.
They're using trunks to protect the water.
Congratulations.
They're using Georgie's poncho to save the fire,
but half the group has tied up trying to collect rainwater.
I can't fucking believe this.
I can't think it's organised when they feed.
Oh, hello, piggies!
Oh, they're getting sheltered.
Oh, it's cooking itself, really.
They're going to roast themselves.
Let them roast themselves.
Is that a tornado?
Wow.
Do you want to see what's inside?
So, there it goes.
It's like a big thing in the sky.
Honestly, I've never seen anything like it.
If that touches down, we're in trouble.
Oh, my God.
At their worst, water tornadoes are capable of travelling up to 150 miles an hour.
If this hits the island, it could destroy everything in its path.
It's like one of those.
It's growing as well.
It is growing.
That's pretty scary.
We're really vulnerable here and no-one can get through anything like that happens.
Well, hang on.
Is it dissipating or is it just curving?
It's gone.
It seems to have just split up and gone.
We'll get to live another day.
Shame.
While they've kept the fire alight, they've hardly collected any water.
Is that the total amount of what we've just got from that rainfall?
Yeah.
I am struggling.
As much as we nest here, Mother Nature turns up and she just shits on it.
And it's like a fucking mudslide everywhere now.
It's become clear to the women they can't survive here on Coconut Beach.
They must move camp.
Whoa!
Five days ago, the women discovered a beach on the western side of the island
with a sustainable water source nearby.
They christened it Home Beach.
Now, Lauren wants to take everyone back there.
You need to get to that Home Beach now.
The beach, the water...
It's just going to make people feel like they can actually do this.
I'm pretty confident in where that beach is.
We do have a serious problem with water.
Hopefully, Home Beach is going to sort all that out.
There's a stream there.
Yeah, and this is the, like, resources.
We can start making our shelters.
You guys haven't seen it.
You guys haven't seen it yet either, have you?
So, I've got this image of this beach that flows for, like, miles.
Palm trees, hammocks, shelter, waterfall, fish jumping from the sea.
Yeah, we saw that. We did see that.
Oh, I'm so excited.
What's the plan with the fire, guys?
Are we going to try and transport it?
We haven't got anything metal, have we, yet?
So, we'll just have to light another one.
It's all right, we're experts now.
I'm excited. It's going to be eight.
Who would like the first snail?
Sage and onion remain off the menu.
Tonight, it's just foraged snails.
It's quite salty, quite meaty,
and then there's this sharp, like, shit, basically.
And a good meal always prompts a lively conversation.
Is that it? That's it.
It's small.
I had the South African with the tiny little penis.
It was definitely a micro-penis because it was smaller than my pinky.
No, like, you know...
I said it was smaller than my pinky!
No, seriously, Beth, it's not even funny.
I really feel for them because no girl could feel that inside them.
Can you imagine?
So, what's the point?
One guy who I was dating just felt like a little twiglet.
The good thing is that they're often really good at cunnilingus.
And then you have to get special condoms
because they're so small and it's just going to slip off otherwise.
Do you actually get special condoms for them?
You can, yeah.
6.30am, day nine.
Honestly adorable.
I'm saying this about a pig.
Oh, and they're very cute. It just made me happy.
Today, the women face an arduous trek,
seeking the beach where they want to build a permanent camp.
What do you think, Jamie?
Is it worth cracking these open to get a mouthful of coconut before we set off?
No, no, it's too heavy. There's loads there.
Oh, I really want a coconut. I'm so hungry.
I'm so hungry, but someone's just said no.
I want you to just take your backpack off and I'm going to give it to Jamie.
It's a hard walk and you will find it difficult.
With very little water for the trek,
Abi and Belinda are especially concerned about PhD student Fran.
I know she's not well, but she doesn't want to leave.
It's really tricky, isn't it?
She doesn't want to make a fuss and she doesn't want to stop this.
I just want to leave the island.
Five days ago, she collapsed and received emergency medical treatment.
I'm really worried about Fran.
Every time she tries to do something, she's feeling light-headed and dizzy.
She's already passed out once due to low blood sugar,
so clearly her body's not very good at adapting to the day.
Shall we make you the bow carrier?
It's actually the most important thing ever.
Yes.
I feel like the weakest person in the group,
because everyone, even though they're really tired, they can keep going.
As I've said before, I just feel like another mouth to feed.
Guys!
Oh, no! No! No!
Havala is reluctant to leave Sage and Onion behind.
Now is time, Gordon.
Come out!
OK, we'll just grab him.
They're wild animals. They just need to be left alone.
I wanted to try.
We can't take the pits.
Guys, we're going to Home Beach!
Woo!
Bye, Sage! Bye, Onion!
Bye, dinner! Bye, lunch!
Look at us! We look like savannahs!
BOOM!
9am.
The women depart for Home Beach.
The last time they went into the jungle, they were lost for three days.
We're going down, Lauren.
This time, 25-year old nurse Lauren leads the way.
Then we're just going to head on this ridge thing.
Julie, how are you feeling?
Fuck off!
Fuck off?
Yeah. That's how I'm feeling.
Woo!
After just half an hour, Becky's in trouble.
Hold up, guys. I've just got a dry mouth.
My water bottle allocation for the day is almost done.
How's everyone doing?
Energy level's zero.
The move will eat into the women's fragile energy reserves,
but it's a gamble they must take, whatever the consequences.
Take five.
I'm feeling so shit.
If this rain keeps on going,
I feel like I'm on the brink of collapsing again.
I don't want to tell anyone cos I feel so pathetic.
I know I can do this.
I just need to keep going.
With the group exhausted, Lauren and Fi volunteer to scout ahead.
Anyone want a biscuit?
Oh, my God! Oh, you bitch!
Just a little biscuit. Just a little barbie biscuit.
Oh.
The advance party are pushing ahead through the jungle.
I think we may have found it.
We have! This is it!
I know. This is our beach!
Oh, my God. So excited.
I feel a surge of energy.
I can hear the sea!
Oh, wow!
Wow! That is amazing.
Woo!
Look at that!
Even in the pisto drain, this place looks ridiculous.
I just think paradise compared to where we've been.
The sea looks bluer. Everything looks better. Everything.
Our pigs! The pigs!
Yay!
They've traipsed all that way after us.
I don't know whether I could eat them now.
Oh!
Aw!
Why the king? They love us!
What the hell?
Ketchup.
I found a ketchup bottle, and I just think that's a sign.
Mm-hm.
Open ketchup.
Ketchup.
The journey has beaten Fran.
This beach is extra cold because it's kind of, like, open.
I don't feel like I can do anything in this weather
because I can't move.
It's a little bit damp.
Oh, thank you so much, hubby.
Aw, I love you.
Coming through the jungle again today,
in pouring rain, has tipped her over the edge.
She's been proper poorly. She's cold all the time.
And so when we're cold, it's, for her, it's like bloody hypothermia.
When you're wet, you're malnourished,
your body temperature just is going to drop,
and it only takes a two-degree drop
to take you right bang into that danger zone for hypothermia.
So the women have an uphill struggle getting Fran warm.
I am on firewood duty.
We need to get dry firewood.
Nothing is dry.
There's just no dry standing wood.
It's not a little bit wet.
Honestly, the place is just soddenly hoarse.
I don't feel that I could cope with another rainstorm.
I don't think I'm medically fit for this.
It really is torture for Fran.
She clearly is not a well person.
I don't even have any sort of rescue meds,
so if she were to collapse,
it would take a while to get any further medical help to us.
What's up, brother?
Fran now feels she has no option.
My body can't take it anymore. Over.
Do you then want to kick off the island?
Yes, please. Over.
I hope you feel so much better, honey.
I think you might have died if you stayed.
And I'm serious.
Thank you.
I think I would as well.
I am absolutely gutted.
I absolutely love Fran.
She's ace.
She's our little baby.
It was going to be my first challenge ever.
But I, for myself, did.
And I'm really gutted that I couldn't complete it.
It's kind of heartbreaking.
I tried so hard.
Fran, bye, my darling.
We love you.
Another one down.
Now we need to go and anchor the others to trees
and make sure none of the others are thinking of leaving.
To lose another team member, it's so demoralising.
And you can just feel the atmosphere in camp at the minute
is just on tenterhooks and everyone's thinking,
I don't know how long I can keep going like this.
Look at this shit.
I know.
What the hell's gone on?
The storm and an extreme high tide
have washed up a potential treasure trove.
Like Paradise Beach, no longer.
Oh!
False alarm, half a hair clip.
Ta-da!
Not only is it a can, it's a can with a lid.
I think one of the real unsung heroes in the survivors' arsenal
is resourcefulness.
What's that?
Is that iron brew?
Oh, my God.
I thought it was iron brew.
Here, here, hold that, hold that.
Oh, my God.
Wait, check the cell by day.
I don't care.
Oh, my God.
Shh.
So powerfully sweet.
So sugary, like, set up.
And it was just heaven, absolute heaven.
It actually just dropped on my tongue
and it felt like ecstasy, absolute ecstasy.
The women hope the wood is now dry enough
to somehow light a fire
to purify the water from a nearby pond.
This is filled up good.
Thank God for that.
Yeah, for some reason.
Thank God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
It's usually on a fire starter.
Woo!
Hang on, hang on.
Hang on.
Wait, hold on, we haven't lit a fire yet.
This is, like, so early.
Please don't go out.
To fucking wet.
Shit, what are we going to do?
Oh, my God.
Shit, what we're going to do?
Good work, Georgie.
Nothing happens without a fire.
We've got those things.
It's, it's, it's...
I can't believe how...
It's an inverted triangle.
Yeah.
Fire.
And everything comes off with a truck of fire.
That's it.
Without fire, we are...
I don't have any survival skills, but I'm absolutely happy to step up to the plate if
a crocodile needs killing, or...
Yeah.
snake needs its head chopping off and I think the key to our survival on the
island is teamwork I was actually caught in the tsunami in Sri Lanka we didn't
eat or sleep for four days so I have an understanding of what that mental
pressure is
my stopping enough pressure on it I think I'm not putting enough pressure on
it harder she tries Georgie can't get it to
light even now the wood is drier sup Jules it's half past two now no sign of
the fire
he's had any spindle left is the thing it's probably right flicking off nice
and slow that's it keep it like that the battle
for an
ember continues through the night
getting a little bit panic we're starving and thirsty I surely I'm gonna
die soon fucking stupid place the women have now been without water for more
than 48 hours and they are dangerously dehydrated I feel really drained and
really faint
I'm dead
okay to you Lauren
me
yeah me
fucker
it wasn't like that
I think we've lost this one haven't we
so this bow drill set really all the parts need to be in perfect proportion
for this to work the problem is the women's drill is now too small because
it's been so used they need to start again their situation is now beyond
critical
feel so dizzy it's fucking hard work when you've not drunk anything and the
heat
I'm really struggling it feels like a purpose on this island it's just to be
dehydrated
just to be dehydrated
it's just a bit dehydrated
I'm so tired.
Pot shot to barbell one, over.
I just wanted to let you know we need some supplies from you.
Medical advice is that the castaways
are now so critically dehydrated that within a few hours,
their lives will genuinely be in danger.
So, really, I've got no choice but to intervene,
and the women will be given a working bow drill set.
Right, fire startings, bitters.
Let's do this.
It's purring, ladies, it's purring, actually.
Oh, yes!
Yes! Woo-hoo!
Woo-hoo!
Well done!
This is amazing, isn't it?
This is great.
Woo!
Now we can start thinking about the bigger things,
like our bellies, for example.
There's a little something down there
which is sitting a bit dangerously close to the fire to me.
This is amazing.
It's cool and clear.
And that view, I feel like we're in a luxury hotel.
And then, shortly, our butler will come.
What have you ordered for butler service?
Oh, oysters.
Oh, no, not oysters. We can get them here.
Oh, yeah!
Order something you can't get here.
What would be your first?
Double cheeseburger.
Absolute whopper with everything on it.
I want to find out what you...
Now, what have you ordered from our butler?
From our room service.
I've started with some deep...
Well, sorry, it is seafood, actually.
No, really?
Some deep-fried calamari.
Deep-fried calamari.
Oh.
And then, for some weird reason,
it's a bit like being pregnant,
I want jelly and custard and ice cream.
And I don't even like ice cream.
But I'd like, you know, jelly, custard and ice cream.
And then, a kids' buffet.
Oh, kids' buffet. I'm with you with that.
Until I vomit.
Day 12 on the island.
The women now have fire and plenty of drinking water,
but they're barely surviving on just 50 calories a day.
It took me I don't know how many hours
to get that many almonds.
It's going to be one almond, if we're lucky.
After almost two weeks without a meal,
the group is at the point of starvation.
If they don't eat soon, there's a genuine risk
their organs will start to shut down.
I'm fucking hungry.
My tummy has gone away.
I literally have no tummy.
Look.
Flat, flat, flat, flat, flat.
My stomach's going, I'm going to have to eat myself.
Is that not the cutest thing you've ever seen?
Hi, Sage and Onion.
The fate of Sage and Onion hangs in the balance.
The women have befriended them
and now can't agree whether or not
to eat them.
I keep looking at those gorgeous pigs
as bits of food.
They're too cute.
We can't, I can't.
Now, imagine this.
Barbecue sauce over the ribs, right?
Barbecue sauce, barbecue sauce, barbecue sauce, right?
Even the tail, really good, really chewy,
I'd still eat it.
I think we should spit roast it.
Put a steak up through its bum.
Not through its mouth, through its head, of course.
Obviously, I've got a completely different point of view
to the rest of the girls.
Because I don't eat meat, but...
Sage and Onion, they're little peglets
and definitely not eating none.
We've got two pigs, Sage and Onion,
which have become our pet pigs.
They've followed us all the way from Coconut Beach here,
which is a long walk for little legs.
They were thriving at the other beach.
What's lacking here that they could get at the other beach?
They were digging up lots of roots at the other beach.
It was really muddy,
so the water collected in the mud was in the sand.
Water doesn't really collect.
We have to set a limit to how much we do
that compromises our resources over the pigs.
Over the past few days,
people have been laid down with double vision,
retching and not being able to walk.
People are really suffering,
and you need to eat to survive.
Nobody wants to kill anything, but we need to eat.
Understandably, you know, a lot of people find the hard work,
the whole concept of killing animals,
it's either cruel, it's upsetting,
and, yes, it's never pleasant to take a life,
but in a survival situation, when it comes down to the wire,
it's a simple choice, them or you.
You're really upset, everybody's really upset.
Can we show of hands that we agree that we do something soon?
So, Jamie, where's your mind thinking at the moment?
I don't want anything to do with this.
Well, who's going to kill it?
Well, that's the next question.
I have volunteered myself to do it...
Well done, Lauren.
..just because I know that I'll do it fast.
I'm going to get a little dehydrated, so I'll have a little drink.
He's crying out more than he's taken it.
Oh, that's all right.
You see, it was wrong to all get attached to them, wasn't it?
I always say, once you've named something, you're screwed.
Yeah.
The reason I'm so upset
is because they reminded me of my dog.
And...
..I really thought we were going to have some
until we left the island.
It makes everything real.
It makes everything...
..like...
..raw.
It's pretty raw, isn't it? Yes!
It's raw.
Erm, I just want to make it the most, like, peaceful...
..death.
You know, like, if I was panicking,
then it would feel that.
If anyone sees a good whacker...
I'm not annoyed at anybody.
I just don't want to have any part of it.
As long as I don't see it or hear it,
it just stops it.
Just gently holding out,
cos I don't want him to struggle,
I just want him to be relaxed.
But I tell you what,
they've had a little better life than most pigs in captivity
that have bred to the pork.
The pork we eat and the chops I buy
and the sausages I buy,
they've had no life at all.
I don't know another pig that's gone to bed with a load of people.
Ready? Should race.
Absolutely. Yeah.
One, two, three.
THEY LAUGH
Well, Lauren, absolutely amazingly well done.
You did the job really, really well. Really well.
It was quick. Quick.
And it was painless.
That was pretty emotional, wasn't it?
It was pretty horrible.
It's never easy to take a life,
but having learnt from this first kill,
they actually dispatched the second animal swiftly, cleanly,
no hesitation.
Yeah, I'm glad it wasn't distress.
Shall we get it back and get it on the barbecue?
I've never, ever killed an animal before,
especially as a girl, as well,
is that I don't think we're designed to want to kill anything,
and that's what has been a huge limit
on the burning curve for me.
You know, it's reality.
That's what it is, it's brutal reality,
that if you want to eat,
then you are going to have to kill something.
Gosh, Lauren, she's...
She was the first to volunteer for the pig.
She's very matter-of-fact, very hard-working.
Actually, if I could channel a little bit of Lauren,
I'd be very happy, because she's very impressive.
We needed something that was going to kick-start us
into not viewing animals as pets,
but rather as a way that is going to allow us to survive.
You know, it's going to give us the energy that we need
to get hunting, get finding water, to find wood,
because that is all exhausting work.
It's very sad, but if I'm perfectly, perfectly honest,
I'm really looking forward to the meat,
because I think we're all in dire need of a bit of a meal.
Harvey, just to let you know, the pig's on the fire.
I'm not being a hypocrite. I'll look later.
I'm just not ready. Thank you.
There's no way I'm going to end here until it's all done with.
I wouldn't go in there. I'm not eating a pig.
This is a really decisive moment
in a women's struggle for survival.
Now they have the mindset to progress as hunters and killers.
They've actually crossed a very important cycle
and a very important psychological line,
and for the first time, they're behaving like survivors.
Are you ready, guys?
Yeah.
This tastes good.
Oh, my God. It's unbelievably delicious.
I don't like the fact that I'm eating the piggy, but it is good.
I don't know about anyone else, but I feel like a wild animal.
SHE LAUGHS
Like a cavewoman.
Do you know what that tube is? It's a testicle.
I don't know. I quite like things like that.
Do you know what I mean? It's quite savage.
We needed that.
I'm not going to lie.
It was gorgeous.
Erm, I could have ate it all myself.
It's all good.
That's it for now. Over and out.
Next time on The Island...
You lazy bunch of bone-idle bastards!
We're not even halfway through and tensions are beginning to fray.
We're not all just grunts that bash on bits of wood.
The sun would look like you didn't want to do a harder job.
I would say, fuck you to that person.
Fucking calm down, eh?
There is absolutely no food in this camp.
This island is infested.
Gee-bye!
Roundy boy!
Shit!